hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
i'm extremely excited
because as you probably know by now more
and more leaks and rumors have been
coming out
pointing to apple releasing a new fully
redesigned 24-inch imac
at apple's april event next month and
just the other day
9-5 mac basically confirmed it they did
some digging into the latest mac os big
sur beta
and found references to two unreleased
imac models
the imac 21-1 and 21-2
now this is an absolutely huge deal for
a couple of different reasons
first off they also found references to
the unreleased a14x chip
within the latest ios 14.5 beta
which is destined to go into the ipad
pro
which at this point we know is 100
getting released within the next month
probably at apple's april event
no doubt about it and then the second
reason is that
last year the identifier for one of the
m1 max was leaked within mac os beta
code
and then just a couple of weeks later
the m1 max were
officially released at apple's november
event so based on that there's a very
good chance that both of these leaked
imac models are coming
sooner than later probably at apple's
april event next month
which is extremely exciting because
we've been waiting for them
for many many months however there is
still
one question that remains unclear do
those two identifiers automatically mean
that both the 24 inch imac and the
larger
27 to 30 inch imac are coming next month
well i personally don't think so because
of two main reasons
so let's get right into it first off
there have been quite a few leaks
pointing to a 23 or 24 inch imac
coming sometime around the first quarter
of 2021
but all of those leaks don't mention
anything
about the larger imac model at the same
time
bloomberg reported that they're not
expecting the imax until much later in
the year
but due to the massive amount of 24-inch
imac leaks we've recently seen
it's likely that they were talking about
just the larger imac model coming later
last year we also got a lot of rumors of
apple working on a dedicated custom gpu
which was destined for the larger imac
coming in the second half of 2021
which makes a lot of sense since that
machine needs to be
very powerful so in this case i don't
think all of that super powerful
hardware is ready to launch
next month and therefore i believe that
the larger imac should actually be
launching
later in the year and then for the
second reason the 27-inch intel imac
that we got last year
surprisingly also came with two separate
identifiers
yes two codes for the same 27 inch imac
so we started to do some research and we
found that it's likely not due to the 10
gigabit ethernet upgrade option
because the intel mac mini offers that
as well
and it only has one identifier it's most
likely not the nano texture glass
since that doesn't really impact the
internals at all
but then we dug into geekbench results
and found that every single mac with the
20-2 identifier
has a different motherboard than the
20-1 models
and then we also found that the 20-2
models always come
with the higher-end 5700 and 5700
xt gpus so the question is this
why would it need a different
motherboard for those
gpus well it turns out that the 27-inch
imac
supports up to two 6k external displays
but only if you get the radeon pro 5700
or 5700 xt graphics and then we dug a
little deeper
and found that you also need an extra
thunderbolt controller
to support that much display bandwidth
and yes
an extra controller and larger gpu
means that you need an entirely
different motherboard
and that's where the second identifier
for the same 27 inch model came from
i then researched a bit more and found
that the 2017
21.5 inch imac actually has two
identifiers as well one for the base
1080p
model and one for the 4k model
and if you look at the tech specs you'll
notice that the base imac
does not get a dedicated graphics chip
it relies on the intel cpus integrated
graphics
and therefore it probably has a totally
different motherboard
without the socket and wiring used by
the dedicated gpu
hence why there is two separate
identifiers
for the same 21.5 inch imac so the point
that i'm trying to make
is that both of those leaked imac
identifiers could
actually be the same 24-inch imac model
that's coming next month and that would
make a lot of sense
because the rumors are pointing to the
larger imac only coming later in the
year
so here is the big question we have to
answer
why would the 24-inch imac have two
separate identifiers
well my money is on it actually having
two separate motherboard options
just like we saw with those intel models
that we just looked at
so now the question is what would
warrant
two separate motherboards on the same
model well
i did some more digging and i came up
with this
the 24 inch imac will most likely have
two apple silicon chip options the m1
chip that we already have
and the new m1x chip as an upgrade
option
which will require a different
motherboard
due to the chip being physically larger
so let me explain how i got to that
conclusion
many months ago before the m1 max
bloomberg reported that apple will use a
12
core 5 nanometer arm processor and the
very first apple silicon mac
in 2021 with eight performance cores and
four
efficiency cores which is what we are
calling
the m1x chip however the first apple
silicon mac
chip was actually the m1 an 8 core chip
and it actually came in 2020 earlier
than bloomberg
reported so here is what i think
happened
apple was planning redesigned macbooks
with mini led displays
but then they ended up getting delayed
due to the pandemic
so apple just went ahead and tossed a
less powerful acore chip
into the macbook air the pro and the mac
mini
without making any other changes knowing
that they're going to give
that other 12 core chip to the
redesigned macbooks
sometime in 2021. now going back to
bloomberg's original report
they said that three mac chip designs
based on the 5 nanometer a14 chip
are in development so that's probably
the 8 core
m1 the 12 core m1x and
one more mystery chip which i personally
believe will be called
the m1z now a few months later after the
launch of the m1 max
bloomberg gave us some more juicy
details on
more chips apparently apple is working
on apple silicon chips with as many as
32 high performance cores that could
appear
in a mac in late 2021 which i honestly
think is the mystery m1z chip
that's destined for the larger imac
that's coming later this year
but the interesting detail i want to
focus on is the report that apple is
developing a chip
with 16 high performance cores and four
efficiency cores essentially making it a
20 core chip
and what makes it very interesting is
that bloomberg noted
that apple might choose to release the
20 core chip with
only 8 or 12 of the high performance
cores enabled
depending on how mass production goes so
that would mean that the same
20 core chip will be turned into a 12
core or 16 core chip by using a method
called
binning so let me explain how that works
when chip manufacturers start mass
producing
brand new chip designs there are often
some flaws
with the chip with some of the cores
failing to pass
quality standards so instead of tossing
out the entire chip and taking a loss on
it
they'll instead disable some of the
cores and then
advertise it as a slightly weaker chip
to at least be able to make a sale on it
and guess what apple is already doing
this with the m1 chip
which is intended to have an a core gpu
but the base model macbook air only
comes with
seven so apple is already taking
advantage of binning
to sell the flawed chips instead of
throwing them away
now getting back to that 20 court ship
that apple is set to be developing
bloomberg says that they could arrive as
early as spring 2021
which would be perfect to reveal
at apple's april event and since this 20
core chip is going to be very ambitious
they can take advantage of bidding to
make sure that every single chip that
they create
can be sold and the only way to do that
is to disable at least four of those
high performance cores
on every single chip to make sure they
can use
all of them and in the worst case
scenario
they can disable eight of those high
performance cores
making it a 12 chord ship in total and
it would be perfect
to name it the 12 core m1x channel now
if you're starting to lose me here
let's take those chips and apply them to
the mac
lineup where it's going to make a whole
lot more sense let's say that the 24
inch imac
comes out next month at apple's april
event where they also announce
the m1x chip if they decide to keep the
very cheap 1100
base model for the 24 inch imac then it
will almost
surely come with the same 8 core m1 chip
that we already have
but then you'll also have the option of
upgrading to either a 12
core m1x chip or even a 16 core
m1x jam that sounds like a pretty decent
amount of upgrade options to me
for a 24 inch imac and it would make
sense why it would need to have two
separate identifiers
since the m1x chip might actually
require a different motherboard
due to the larger size of the chip
itself now on top of that
keep in mind that the m1x chip will also
have varying amounts of gpu cores as
well
bloomberg reported that apple is
currently testing models
with 16 and 32 gpu cores
so what if the 12 core m1x chip
comes with 16 graphics cores and the 16
core m1x chip comes with 32
now that honestly sounds a bit too good
to be true
so maybe apple is going to utilize gpu
bidding
to bring it down to maybe 24 or 28
cores to be a bit more realistic and
then later this year
potentially as late as december apple
could come out with a higher end imac
that comes with the 12 core m1x at the
base price
which you could then upgrade to the 16
core m1x
or ultimately the 32 core m1z model
that bloomberg reported that apple was
working on and then on top of that
i expect the larger imac model to also
have an option for a custom dedicated
apple gpu
which we've been seeing leaks of for
some time now making it the
ultimate imac and because of that
i think apple is going to be taking
advantage of the imac pro branding
for that larger imac since i also think
it's going to be getting a mini led
display
like michiko reported on a while back so
you'll basically just have
one model of the imac the 24 inch
coming at the april event next month and
then you're going to get a larger
27 to 30 inch imac pro
coming at the end of the year now of
course all of this
is pure speculation so if you disagree
with me
go ahead and let me know down in the
comment section below but if you think
that all of this matches up with the
speculation and all the leaks
go ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video